à 9h15 sur intensité en jette un coup
d'oeil
jérôme a débuté comme bénévole il ya dix
ans aujourd'hui célarié il assure trois
heures d'antenne chaque jour nous on
essaie de ceux de s'investir sur le
terrain avec des émissions délocalisé
par exemple aux artisanales à chartres
on est en direct pendant quatre jours du
salon
la foire expo de châteaudun les forums
des associations de chartres là le
week-end dernier
on essaie vraiment de faire un maximum
d'émissions comme ça budget annuel
300000 euros l'essentiel des ressources
via de la publicité 9 septembre 1985
c'est la toute première émission de
radio intensité
trente ans plus tard quinze bénévoles
lui salariés intensité reste une radio
associative son président depuis vingt
ans évoque le secret d'une telle
longévité poursuivre continuer le plus
longtemps possible avec les moyens que
quand y en a plus c'est un homme investi
en essayent de faire des choses
nouvelles on essaye de voir on a mis un
site internet qui marche très bien mais
avec peu de moyens et voilà et on essaye
de de faire tout cela donc comme ça avec
les idées des bénévoles des salariés de
tous de toute l'équipe en fait bonjour à
tous les pompiers ont multiplié les
interventions cet été ont raison nicolas
sur le matinal il est arrivé à 5h30 du
matin ont fait en même temps des
journaux le matin mais on peut aussi
être de reportages on est trois
journalistes à plein temps à la radio ce
qui fut une importante rédaction pour
une radio comme intensité mais voilà on
touche à peu près à tous ont fait de la
présentation fait également du
reportages des interviews donc voilà
c'est vraiment le grand intérêt de
travailler dans une radio locale en
mettant l'accent sur l'info de proximité
et malgré la crise
la radio se porte bien avec une audience
en hausse de 10% par rapport à l'an
passé